This video is brought to you by movie it
curated online cinema,
streaming exceptional films from around
the globe.
Get your first month for free at
[inaudible] dot com slash storytellers.
Really relating to these archetypes in
the master.
You don't have energy,
you will not have a sense of
if they have
that stuff out in ways that are
destructive coming from you and others.
What is masculinity?
Is it an outdated and overall
destructive construct or is it a
necessary aspect of our humanity and the
maturation of the individual?
These are some of the questions that
pervade the work of Michael Mann in
general and his film collateral in
particular because even though it's
story of a gabby being forced to drive a
contract at killer from hit to hit
during one night in la might seem
shallow.
On the surface level,
I believe it's symbolic and thematic
structure provides a meaningful
meditation on what it means to adopt
they healthy masculinity and what
happens when we attempt to repress it
within ourselves and our societies.
In one of his early seminars,
Dr [inaudible] discussed the
mythological symbol of the men or the
rider and the bull and the necessity of
taming once interval,
once masculine and animal nature.
It is still the old hero cold of the man
who was capable of teaming his own bull
like fashions,
the man who can overcome himself as
almost a god and soda man who a has
deemed himself he's overcome his fears.
Thus,
the catching of the ball in the net is
an age old symbol for the self education
of men.
When we're first introduced to Max,
we initially get a sentence that this is
a man who's got his life together.
He used to Gabby,
who goes above and beyond to keep things
orderly and clean.
He used to driver who knows his roots by
heart and ain't for maximum efficiency
and take the 105 to 1:10 this fast,
but he's also a people's person
perceptive in his ability to put himself
in his passenger shoes,
compassionate to their struggles,
to take the ticket because you needed a
lot more than I do.
Next is a man who excels at what he
does,
who blends them,
doing so much more limo company.
I'm putting together island limos and
who even gets the number of the girl he
likes without even having to ask for it.
Max Truly seems to have it all.
It's not until after a mysterious man
from out of town and enters a scab that
the facade begins to crumble.
Denver,
Oh,
you been driving 12 years.
Really
suddenly,
Max is excellence and orderliness as a
cab driver are exposed to be barred if
it's a weakness for in reality,
Max is all order.
No risk it chronic clunker of life like
a faceless writer or missing action.
He's become complacent,
stuck in a routine,
afraid of getting dirty,
of taking a chance.
If the girl he likes of delving into the
unknown of facing his inner bull,
why don't you just take the cat?
Is Realistic.
Ambitions have turned into an escapist
dream meant to deceive himself as well
as others from facing his reality.
He grabs famous people around limousine
companies,
and that's what an achievement for.
It's when we repress our inner
masculinity,
when we don't listen to our instincts,
forfeit our assertiveness,
our healthy aggression,
you tell them to take next cab,
and when we don't take responsibility
for our lives,
that life itself becomes rigid,
constricting,
claustrophobic,
even the car becomes not a symbol of
freedom,
but one of bondage in a world seemingly
indifferent to our existence
like Max,
we might dream or deceive ourselves and
others into believing that nothing is
wrong,
but in reality when we repress our inner
bull,
we've become small,
the pendant harmless and therefore
vulnerable.
Not much more than cogs in a machine
marionettes stuck in an endless loop
naively waiting for the universe to give
us our do.
Someday,
someday my dream will come
when you wake up and you'll discover it
never happened.
You can avoid places where bools are to
be found and if you don't see them,
you will not be bothered,
but you must be dodging all the time in
order to avoid every possibility of a
rousing.
And since life provides endless
opportunities for the emotions,
there is no end of dodging which amounts
to a panic or a chronic flunking of
life.
Vincent is in all aspects the opposite
of Max,
his shadow.
He seems to fully identify with the
masculinity of the symbolic bull.
Everything Max is not.
He shows himself to be assertive,
alert,
and most of all,
aggressive and unpredictable.
If Max is constricted by too much order
and routine.
Vincent relishes in chaos and
improvisation
tough now behind the notes,
not what's expected.
Compromise.
And yet vincent is not the perfect
manifestation of the writer who is
deemed the passions of the bull.
He believes that compassion and emotion
of Max to be a hypocritical weakness of
character,
tens of thousands kill before sundown.
Nobody's killed people that fastens,
Nagasaki and Hiroshima.
Did you bat an Imax?
Do Vincent who grew up in an abusive
household life has no inherent meaning
or value.
And the people who claim the opposite
are lying to themselves.
Six hours.
He's riding the subway before anybody
notices his corpse doing laps around La
people on an opposite next to him.
Nobody notices.
I didn't notice the way he shot.
He shot as a part of the landscape.
All that kind of stuff was to kind of
make him feel like an animal in la,
that he is a product of this great urban
sprawl that we live in,
kind of a thing.
Vincent is a product
of modern urban society,
an extreme rationalist nihilist his gray
and colorless attire,
revealing his inner hollowness
ultimately act only to prove as
resentful belief that the world is
disconnected,
cruel,
and indifferent to existence or bringing
death and misery jewelers.
Vincent has become possessed by what
Robert Moore termed the archetypical
shadow warrior,
the destructive side of masculinity.
He's become detached from emotion and
human relationships.
He's disgusted by human pettiness and
weakness and lifts only for his mission
to him,
the emotional bastions of the bull
orbits,
silly constructs of society or the human
imagination ultimately holding one back
from taking unrestrained action to
achieve one's goals.
He takes what he needs from it.
Symbolic animal for his own egoistic
needs and things he can leave to carcass
behind Giran now,
double should not be killed.
It is not a bull sacrifice because we
have learned what that means.
It means that you are deprived of life,
drained if the very juice of life,
if you kill the emotional powers in
yourself,
you get absolutely petrifying,
dried up that therefore you must try to
keep that ball live under certain
conditions symbolized by the net and the
tight feed.
The ball must live,
and so as these two opposites embarked
together on their murderous night,
an interplay of personalities and sue's
visually Max's self-contained window
into the world is cracked and his life
is thrown into chaos.
After you realize the true identity of
his diabolical passenger,
as he drives Vincent from hit to hit,
his own insufficiency becomes clear as
the veil of his lying is slowly being
lifted.
I'm not up for this and as much as you'd
love to escape,
his reality is dependence on others will
only bring him in the world.
More pain.
You attract attention.
You're going to get people killed.
He didn't need to be.
He stuck into cab in the enclosed arena
with his bull beside him.
The only way out is to move forward into
the unknown and it's in spending time
with him that he slowly becomes more
comfortable,
more level headed,
and begins to learn from Vincent's
behavior slowly becoming more assertive.
I'm going to have to stick this yellow
cab of your fat ass and improvisational
to realization dawns on Max that the
only way to survive the night and to
beat Vincent is to be like Vincent.
The only way to team to dangerous bull
is to consciously act like the bull.
One of the aspects of that becoming a
man is becoming dangerous if you're not
dangerous.
Power masking the maturation has to do
with being empowered and knowing how to
use it and when not to use.
Tell the guy behind me to put his gun
away before I take it into Peter's
bitter as definitely an embodying.
His inner vincent.
Max has discovered a new found power he
previously didn't know he had,
but by acting like the board of warrior,
there's always the danger of becoming or
being as its opposite
Vincent Vincent.
So what I'm hearing seemingly blurring
the line between the warrior and it's
shadow counterpart,
confusing to police on who the real
hitman is supposed to be.
It is only through to murder of
detective fenning.
That then since true ethological nature
is exposed,
there's no reason,
good reason,
there's no bad reason they've ordered
that a cop.
You may
notice this
in complete shock of incense.
Nihilistic worldview Max makes a final
move towards the completion of his inner
journey by taking full responsibility
for his life
straight up and looked at it.
Sure.
His own hesitance to act,
his passive defendants have caused them
to stagnate in life,
is weakness in lines if not only held
himself back,
but have also contributed to the
suffering of others is fail of the seed
has now been lifted completely and can
therefore exists.
No longer you don't want that's
fucked yourself.
Is deliberate.
Crashing of this gap then becomes an
image of a symbolic death and
resurrection is shedding of weakness.
The marionette dies and a writer arises.
The bull has been teamed and the shadow
warrior has failed in his attempt to
convert him into his ranks.
And the sleeves is sign,
but there's one more step needed for Max
to complete his inner journey,
the capacity to be a long time on
whether or not you can care enough or
something that is totally unrelated to
your personal interests that you can see
the trend,
egoic,
Max strength sentences own being by
sacrificing his own safety in order to
save the woman he cares about who also
comes to represent the society as a
whole in her role as assistant attorney.
And so by taking responsibility,
by embodying the archetype of the
warrior,
Max is not only fighting for another
individual,
but for the good of society as a whole.
He surprises to shadow warrior and this
new found ability to take decisive
action.
Why?
What are you going to do about it?
But he also exposes the weakness and
Vincent's character.
Max ultimately does not win the final
clash because of his competence with
firearms or through his aggression,
but by improvising on the spot.
Whereas Vincent sticks to is rigid and
pathological nature to sternum.
When the head is inability to
emotionally connect with others,
and the one person who made himself
conscious of is flawed nature ultimately
become his downfall.
He stoically accepts death almost as
part of his job and yet in his final
words,
we hear it a boy,
so he broken men,
a forgotten child.
It's on the MTA.
Hearing guys
for Max life begins again.
The repressed passive men who started
the night is no more in display stands a
writer with a ball in this net.
He is not killed it for he knows it to
be impossible,
naive,
immoral,
and so yes,
tamed his masculinity without becoming
possessed by,
by embodying his inner pool,
not for chaos and destruction,
but for the good of himself and those
around him.
He opens the door to a meaningful life,
to an existence with purpose to a new
beginning
is the cause.
We have such a little experience of the
positive side of this and where your mum
that we become so cynical and sometimes
even I listed about masculinity and
begin to equate masculinity was
patriarchy,
which is very common and intellectual
rounds today in my view.
The two are not to be equated at all at
all.
Thank you to movie for sponsoring.
This video movie is a curated streaming
service that makes it a lot easier to
find a good movie to watch because at
any given time they have just 30 films
available everyday.
A film is added and everyday one is
taken away with timeless classics,
thought provoking documentaries and
acclaimed masterpieces.
Movies,
assortment of films is perfect for
anyone looking to expand our cinematic
horizons with something new.
For instance,
if you like collateral,
this Sunday in the U.
s movie is launching a special weekend
on the claimed Hong Kong director of
Johnny Toe,
showcasing three of us films dedicated
to a suspenseful stories of men driven
today are very limits.
Head over to [inaudible] dot com slash
storytellers for an extended free trial.
Again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash
storytellers for a 30 day free trial.
Thank you.